la desolación reina en nec hay una de
las zonas más golpeadas por el terremoto
de magnitud 7,2 que sacudió haití miles
de viviendas quedaron convertidas en
escombros y la devastación deja miles de
muertos e importantes daños materiales
dos líneas de concesión el princismo
canales salía de mi negocio con
normalidad cuando sentí el movimiento
mientras caminaba mira al frente y sentí
que la tierra se movía y que todo se
caía cuando llegué a mi casa me di
cuenta de la extensión del daño
de acá que también fue bomba a cosas
muchas personas han perdido todo y se
encuentran en campamentos improvisados y
sobre poblados
desde el terremoto no me siento bien
estamos en esta cancha de fútbol muchas
personas se encuentran aquí nuestra casa
está destruida la tierra la corto cloud
lo patea de la cae no en medio de este
panorama la ayuda comienza a llegar el
gobierno pretende realizar un reparto
ordenado y apela al respaldo de los
ciudadanos
noble
sandy bay and english en esta crisis
queremos respuestas más adecuadas que
las posteriores al terremoto de 2010
todo ayuda que venga del exterior debe
pasar por la dirección de protección
civil no quiero que la asistencia llegue
de manera desordenada donde todos
decidan qué quieren
[Música]
mientras tanto las tareas de rescate y
limpieza continúan con apoyo extranjero
como el de la guardia costera de eeuu a
medida que avancen las operaciones las
autoridades consideran probable que el
número de víctimas aumente